[Musik]
was tun gegen die delta variante
gesundheitsexperten der opposition
fordern mit einer schnelleren
zweitimpfung die mutation einzudämmen
großbritannien und das delta problem die
korona zahlen steigen wieder stark mehr
als 10.000 menschen infizieren sich
täglich und jump zurück auf der bühne
der erste große auftritt seit monaten
tausende feiern ihn als anführer der
republikaner
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zur sonntagsausgabe der heute
-nachrichten norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport ein stück
genau der familie seit wochen sinken die
korona zahlen in deutschland trotzdem
warnen gesundheitspolitiker immer lauter
vor der delta variante um zu verhindern
dass sie die zahl wieder steigen lässt
kommt jetzt der vorschlag die zweit
impfungen vorzuziehen
aktuell haben hierzulande mehr als die
hälfte der menschen eine erste impfung
bekommen vollständig geimpft sind fast
35 prozent und nur die sind wirksam
gegen die data variante geschützt stefan
lobenstein stuttgart ins zentrum
aktuell sind hier 90 prozent der impfung
zweitimpfung wichtig denn nur nach zwei
impfungen besteht auch der volle schutz
gegen die derzeit sich weiter
verbreitende gefährliche delta variante
schneller impfen sie finden es gut
dann hat man einen kompletten schutz ja
und warum zu vermeiden dass sich das
delta schneller ausbreitet als gedacht
finde ich gut wenn der impfstoff
geheißen
angesichts der höheren erkrankungsraten
fordern auch gesundheitsexperten der
opposition diese wartezeit zwischen den
impfungen zu verkürzen
das ist der einzige wirkungsvolle schutz
gerade gegen die hoch gefährdeten
risikogruppen in unserer gesellschaft
deshalb ist es wichtig hier mehr tempo
zu machen
derzeit liegt die von der ständigen
impfkommission empfohlen eine wartezeit
bei astrazeneca bei zwölf wochen bei
moderner und biotech bei sechs wochen
die hersteller hätten kürzere zeiten für
möglich sagt der chef der
zulassungsbehörde zwischen drei und
sechs wochen innerhalb dieses zeitraums
ist gesichert dass sie eine hohe
wirksamkeit haben
die ständige impfkommission überprüft
nun diese zeitabstände impf drive-in im
hessischen babenhausen haben sie seit 35
spritzen verteilt ohne termin standen
3000 dosen johnson & johnson bereit
vorteil hier nur eine impfung ist nötig
bei der delta variante wie gesagt ist
johnson johnson nicht die erste wahl ja
das ist einfach nicht so effektiv aber
besser als keine impfung genaue zahlen
zur wirksamkeit wird der hersteller noch
vorlegen wie schnell sich die korona
lage wieder drehen kann zeigt sich in
großbritannien 95 prozent der
neuinfektionen gehen auf die delta
mutation zurück die geplante aufhebung
der korona maßnahmen ist verschoben die
em spiele im londoner wembley stadion
mit 10.000 zuschauern halten experten
deshalb für keine gute idee allein so
sah das gestern aus im wembley stadion
beim spiel italien gegen österreich
freude tränen umarmungen ein fußball
fest feiern verträgt sich eben nicht
besonders gut mit abstand halten knapp
19.000 zuschauer waren im stadion am
dienstag sollen es 45.000 sein
dabei treibt die delta variante die
infektionszahlen in die höhe
gestern waren es fast 18.000 neue
infektionen so viel wie seit anfang
februar nicht mehr
geologen warnen wir haben noch keine
verlässlichen daten im moment ist es
sehr gefährlich so viele menschen an
einem ort zu versammeln
es wäre viel besser vorsichtig zu
bleiben und nur kleinere zuschauerzahlen
zuzulassen
vor allem angesichts der steigenden
infektionszahlen bei jüngeren
denn besonders in schulen bereitet sich
die variante rasant aus über 16.000
schüler konnten letzte woche wegen einer
corona infektion nicht zur schule gehen
daher würden experten die stadien lieber
zum impfen verwenden als für
fußballspiele um den wettlauf gegen
delta zu gewinnen die regierung johnson
steckt in der zwickmühle einerseits
droht die variante die versprochene
aufhebung der korona beschränkung mitte
juli zu gefährden andererseits will sie
den engländern die fußballfreude nicht
vermiesen
daher wurden die em-spiele kurzerhand
als test veranstaltungen deklariert ein
experiment das bittere folgen haben
könnte
den sportlichen teil von der fußball-wm
gleich von norbert lehmann
zwei tage nach dem amoklauf von würzburg
schwebt keiner der verletzten mehr in
lebensgefahr der zustand einer 39
jährigen habe sich stabilisiert teilte
die polizei mit
bei einer trauerfeier gedachten die
menschen im würzburger dom heute der
drei todesopfer und beteten für die
verletzten
anwesend waren auch angehörige
polizisten und rettungskräfte vertreter
verschiedener religionen und aus der
politik riefen zu zusammenhalt und
versöhnung auf der polizeieinsatz auf
einer demo in düsseldorf gestern hat
folgen spd und grüne haben eine aktuelle
stunde des landtags beantragt nachdem
polizisten schlagstöcke gegen
demonstranten eingesetzt hatten
dabei wurde auch mindestens ein
journalist attackiert die polizei
berichtete dass teilnehmer gegen das
vermummungsverbot verstoßen und
pyrotechnik abgebrannt hätten
nrw-innenminister reul sagte er werde
den fall prüfen
die demo richtete sich gegen ein neues
versammlungsgesetz in
nordrhein-westfalen doppeltop ist zurück
auf der politischen bühne
fünf monate nach seinem auszug aus dem
weißen haus wird er auf einer
wahlveranstaltung der republikaner von
seinen anhängern gefeiert und behauptet
nach wie vor ohne jeglichen beweis dass
er die präsidentschaftswahl klar
gewonnen hätte im madison
auf den ersten blick hat sich nichts
geändert stundenlang stehen sie schlange
und wollen sich nicht mit tatsachen
abfinden
die wahl wird sich noch drehen alles
wird wie es sein muss
tram hat nicht gewonnen beiden soll
präsident sein schaut her die 50.000
leute sogar ich ein schwarzer
afroamerikaner
tatsächlich aber unterstützen wir ein
paar tausend trump beim rachefeldzug in
seiner eigenen partei
max müller ist trump ist er soll mit
hilfe des ex-präsidenten einem
republikanischen kongressabgeordneten
ablösen der für die amtsenthebung trumps
gestimmt hatte
[Musik]
bei den kommenden wahlen so trump gehe
es um das überleben amerikas joe biden
zerstört unsere nation vor unseren augen
wir werden das abgeordnetenhaus den
senat und ganz amerika zurückerobern und
das schon bei und dann wiederholt er die
lüge von der angeblich gestohlenen bei
sie haben zweimal die wahl gewonnen und
möglicherweise müssen wir sie ein
drittes mal gewinnen noch gibt trump den
ton an in der republikanischen partei
aber selbst manche glühenden anhänger
gingen vorzeitig nach hause
nach dem anschlag im westafrikanischen
mali sind alle zwölf verletzten
bundeswehrsoldaten zurück in deutschland
die maschine mit den letzten verwundeten
landete in der nacht in stuttgart sie
werden jetzt im bundeswehrkrankenhaus in
ulm behandelt
gestern waren schon die am schwersten
verletzten eingeflogen worden
ihr zustand ist laut
verteidigungsministerium statt
in frankreich läuft die zweite und
entscheidende runde der regionalwahlen
sie gilt als letzter stimmungstest vor
der präsidentschaftswahl im nächsten
jahr wie schon im ersten wahlgang
zeichnet sich eine niedrige
wahlbeteiligung ab
in den meisten regionen dominieren
bislang konservative und sozialisten die
rechtspopulisten um marine le pen
schnitten im ersten durchgang schlechter
ab als erwartet
die partei von präsident makro spielt in
den regionen kaum eine rolle
und damit sind wir bei der fußball-wm
und dem rückblick auf ein intensives
achtelfinale zwischen italien und
österreich allerdings von wegen dieses
quadrat sogar glasklarer favorit das war
ein spiel auf augenhöhe
österreich macht es italien so richtig
schwer
erst in der verlängerung die
entscheidung
jubel die italiener und enttäuschte
österreicher die durch marko arnautovic
fast in führung gegangen wären
er stand nur wenige zentimeter im
abseits eigentlich ältere spiel sogar
gewinnen wenn es wenn der markt nicht im
c im abseits gestanden werden
so ging das spiel in die verlängerung
und die eingewechselte federico es dort
matteo pessina trafen für die italiener
kampfstarke österreicher verkürzten
durch den stuttgarter sascha karadzic
doch der 22
einzig der italiener und der einzug ins
viertelfinale nicht unverdient zudem
sind sie jetzt seit 31 spielen
ungeschlagen spannung pur am letzten
spieltag der handball-bundesliga kiel
und flensburg hatten beide die chance
auf die meisterschaft
ja und die nutzte der titelverteidiger
den thw reichte ein 25 25 unentschieden
bei den rhein neckar löwen vieles damit
zum 22
mal deutscher handball meister mathieu
van der poel hat die zweite etappe der
tour de france gewonnen und sich das
gelbe trikot des gesamtführenden geholt
der 26 jährige setzte sich mit sechs
sekunden vorsprung auf titelverteidiger
ktv kasia und dem vorjahreszweiten
primosch roddick durch red bull pilot
max fest appen hat den großen preis der
steiermark gewonnen und seine führung in
der formel 1 auf ausgebaut
der niederländer setzte sich in
spielberg vor weltmeister lewis hamilton
und dessen mercedes teamkollegen
valtteri bottas durch im klassement
liegt button nun 18 punkte vor
und weitere erfolge für den deutschen
tischtennis-bund bei der em in warschau
im frauen doppel holten china und
petrissa solja gold ja und danach trafen
die beiden auch noch im frauen einzel
finale aufeinander
da setzte sich dann petrissa solja
gegenstand aula mit 4 2 1 sätzen durch
und gerade eben hat timo boll auch noch
gold für deutschland geholt im
herreneinzel ja ganz wunderbar viel wird
das steht noch das wetter im osten meist
sonnig im westen wechselnd wolkig und
aufkommende gewitter lokal mit
starkregen hagel und sturmböen
höchstwerte 25 bis 32 grad
auch die kommenden tage bleiben
unbeständig aber zwischendurch wird
immer mal wieder freundlich morgen
begrüßt hier christian sieh was wir
sagen tschüss